it's a familiar story we've heard it so
many times in recent years
the employees of a tech company want to
get the company very involved in
leftist social causes it's so important
to use the company for good and
therefore the company's got to go woke
it's a not so familiar solution when
this company
basecamp just told all of their woke
employees
to shut up and then a bunch of the
employees quit
and the company said don't let the door
hit you on the way out we will
examine this brilliant sophisticated
solution
to the problem of wokeness in
corporations by telling the workers to
go
pound sand base camp oh more like base
camp am i right
am i right finally oh my goodness how
long have we been waiting for a company
to just tell their woke employees
exactly where they can shove
their new leftist ideas the current
the employees go to basecamp which is
just a it's a software company they do
kind of
communication management that sort of
thing
they go to the company they say we've
got to get involved in this cause and
that cause and diversity and inclusion
and equity and this and that and this
and that
and the ceo sent out a note which said
quote
we make project management team
communication
and email software this is the ceo jason
fryde we don't have to solve deep social
problems
chime in publicly whenever the world
requests our opinion on the major issues
of the day
or get behind one movement or another
with time
or treasure these are all important
topics
but they are not our topics at work
other executives at the company pointing
out that when employees are spending all
their time
chiming in on black lives matter or some
social issue on the official
communication channels
that is time that they are not spending
working
doing their jobs the things that they
are paid to do
so as a result of this ceo missive
totally common sense stuff
one third of the company's 60 employees
left the company took buyouts and said
get out of here and you know what the
executive said
see ya bye-bye okay
of course they said see ya bye-bye the
employees thought that this would be a
big blow to the company
guess who comes out ahead here you've
got the most annoying
useless unproductive counterproductive
employees they're saying you know
if you won't let us waste more of your
time while we get paid
we might leave the ceo's ceo sitting
there he
says like what's the catch hold on here
you're telling me
that i will not have to deal with you
and i don't have to deal with you wait
hold on is that you're saying i don't
need to do the thing you're demanding
now and i won't have to deal with it in
the future and i'll get a more
productive employee
where do i sign up where's the hell
there's got to be some
hidden text here right no
there were a number of employees who
after they left
said basically the company has told us
well your opinions don't really matter
unless it's directly related to the
business
a lot of people are going to have a
tough time living with that yeah
annoying unproductive
counterproductive people are going to
have a hard time with that but good
employees are going to love that
they're going to love that because
obviously i have
definitive political opinions you
listening to the show probably have some
pretty strong political opinions
but i bet that you would prefer to go
into the office every day
and not have to worry about those
opinions one way or the other not have
to worry about pushing
this view on tax cuts this view even on
immigration this view on that you
probably just want to go do your job
and then go home and spend time with
your family and spend time in your
community and maybe be involved in the
politics of your community
but not have to conflate everything so
that your whole personal life and your
old professional life and your own
political life they're all the same
thing right
now there is a further step here
so i love what they did i think we
should totally support these guys
but there are three opinions on politics
in the workplace
there's the we need to support every
single leftist cause we need to
go woke because that's now part of the
dominant liberal regime
right that's one the second view is
politics shouldn't have anything to do
with our work
and economic choices shouldn't
necessarily have to do with all these
political views that's too i think
that's where most of us
want to be and that's the message that
base camp is trying to
put out here but then there's the third
version which i think is the real
version which is
we need to actively support conservative
companies
companies that in any way break from
woke politics
we need we as conservatives need to
support those companies
and we need to punish companies that
don't and i know that's going to sound
icky to a lot of people
because a lot of us say well i shouldn't
have to make political decisions when
i'm buying sneakers or when i'm buying
project management software or whatever
at base camp
but you actually do because in politics
and in war your opponent has a say in
the rules of the game
and what the left has told us is that
every economic decision
that you make is going to be political
and they are going to reward the
companies
that go far to the left and undermine
our political order so you know what
we've got to do if we in
any way want to fight back against that
we need to do the same in the opposite
direction
and we need to actively not use the
project management software
that goes woke and we need to actively
use
basecamp or any other company that
resists the wokeness
we have to do that i know that we don't
want to do that we want to go back
to the halcyon days of i don't know four
or five decades ago when the companies
did not go woke but this is the world
we're living in now
and we've got to reward companies like
base camp hey there do not go
anywhere if you've made it here this far
congratulations you have jumped
over all the obstacles that youtube puts
out for you to not see this content
but if you want to make it easier to get
the content ring
the bell like subscribe make sure that
you have the best chance
for big tech not to totally shut you
down and screw up your ability
to check out all of these videos we'll
see you next time